[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute eine schöne motiv
trotte machen und zwar mit dem thema
mini maus und zu mir und ich wir freuen
uns auch schon richtig drauf den
sanierer hat sich schon länger mal eine
mini maus tore gewünscht und als
nächstes wünscht sie sich eine welt
orten eine elser torte also eine
riesentorte und die werden wir jetzt
auch demnächst zusammen machen und bei
motiv torten finde ich es immer ganz
wichtig dass nicht nur das äußere schön
ist sondern auch das innere und bei
vielen ist es eben so dass sie auch
innere nicht so achten
aber ich finde es immer ganz wichtig
dass der kuchen auch ganz gut schmeckt
denn wenn man so eine tolle torte sieht
er hat noch eine ganz große
erwartungshaltung der kuchen muss
absolut gut schmecken und ich kenne zum
beispiel ganz viele cache designer die
selber gar nicht backen können sondern
nur dekorieren können was ich immer ganz
schade finden und deswegen baue ich das
eben bei mir in meinen videos immer mit
ein
und heute gibt es eine leckere
schokoladentorte und das ist jetzt ein
ganz einfaches rezept benutze ich immer
ganz gern für motiv torten weil man auch
keine küchenmaschine braucht der teig
geht ganz schnell
und wenn ihr den am ersten tag
vorbereitet könnte am nächsten tag die
torte dann dekorieren und so machen wir
das jetzt auch am ersten tag bereitet
jetzt den teig zu die creme und einen
teil der decke und am nächsten tag der
kurier daneben fertig für den teig
brauche ich jetzt folgenden zutaten ich
habe hier 320 gramm butter 200
bitterschokolade 250 gramm zucker 890
gramm mehl 30 gramm kakaopulver dann
nehme ich kein cover sondern richtig ist
dunkles kakaopulver 15 teelöffel
backpulver das waren jetzt die zutaten
und wir packen jetzt für dich kleinmann
eine mini maus torte ich bin übrigens
die walt disney filme immer ganz schön
diesen halt so schön lehrreich und ich
finde da kann man mit seinen kindern
zusammen aber eltern und kinder zusammen
sich einmal von fans ersetzen kann die
sich stundenlang angucken und was guckst
du dir gerade an
das buch werde sich auch ganz toll das
habe ich das mir aus der türkei
mitgenommen weil wir lesen auch gerne
türkische bücher und es gibt ja
mittlerweile schon in allen möglichen
sprachen und elsa ist glaube ich so dein
favorit gelten
ich fange jetzt direkt an und zwar
braucht ihr keine küchenmaschine das
mache ich jetzt erstmal hier im topf ich
gebe die butter in den topf und schalte
den herd jetzt auf mittlerer stufe und
gibt da jetzt auch gleich wenn die
butter so ein bisschen angefangen hat zu
schmelzen gebe ich auch gleich die
schokolade mit rein damit sich alles
schön auflösen kann
das
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich diese aufgelöste
schokolade butter mischung in ein großes
gefäß damit früheren hat dies jetzt auch
nicht sehr heißen ich hab's ja nicht
kochen lassen sondern nur erwärmt
ja du darfst du mal den zucker mit laien
geben
ich habe gespritzt
jetzt lese ich den zucker noch ein
bisschen da drin auf
[Musik]
und jetzt lasse ich diese maße noch ein
bisschen abkühlen und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal meine backformen
vorbereiten
ich nehme zu 220 backformen also diese
torten rahmen
ihr könnt auch eine springform benutzen
aber ihr müsst auf jeden fall auf zwei
mal packen denn das ansonsten viel zu
viel teig für eine form so bagdad eick
daneben auch gleichmäßiger und ich habe
auch eine kürzere bauzeit und die schlag
ich jetzt in bagdad 41
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich die eier einzeln mit
dazu also nacheinander und früher sie
schnell ein
man kann das gute sache aber immer nur
eins
[Musik]
als nächstes ferro ich jetzt die
trockenen zutaten miteinander
und die kommen dann direkt mit in dem
teig und dann muss ich sie nur noch kurz
ein rühren
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich den teig auf beide
formen aufteilen und dann werden die im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 165 grad für
etwa 40 minuten gebacken
[Musik]
als nächstes werde ich jetzt die kanal
stellen und die besteht aus zarter
schokolade und sahne
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal die zwei
zutaten gerichtet ich brauche 200 gramm
schlagsahne und 400 gramm ganache und
die werde ich dann eben später benutzen
um die torte damit einzustreichen
zuerst kommt jetzt die sahne in den topf
und da lasse ich sie jetzt kurz
aufkochen
jetzt habe ich den herd wieder
ausgeschaltet die sahne aufgekocht und
jetzt sticht dieser die schokolade mit
susanne ihr könnt es auch gerne anderswo
machen also dass ihr die sahne zur
schokolade mit dazu gibt aber ich finde
so hat ein bisschen mehr restwärme und
es löst sich einfach etwas schneller auf
deswegen mache ich das gerne hier im
topf aber hertens aus sein und jetzt so
lange rühren bis sich die schokolade
komplett aufgelöst hat
[Musik]
und jetzt ist wieder zurück in das
andere gefäß dann muss nämlich die
kanarische erstmal abkühlen und dann
setze ich da einfach kurzen deckel drauf
und lass es einfach bei zimmertemperatur
abkühlen
und wenn es mal schnell gehen muss und
ethikern am gleichen tag machen müsst
können das ja auch ganz kurz in
kühlschrank geben auch oder müssen
aufpassen dass sie nicht zu kalt wird
die torten bilden sind gebacken und
bereits abgekühlt und jetzt kann ich den
torten rahmen lösen
das mache ich mit so einem tortenring
messer
und jetzt dass er noch einen tag rund
denn ansonsten bröseln thema sei und
deswegen gebe ich jetzt einfach
unternimmt kuchen glocke und das macht
ihr am besten so ich leg dir so ein
geschirrtuch drunter und sauberes
natürlich und kann beide übereinander
stapeln und dann so aufbewahren
und jetzt kann ich schon mal ein
bisschen deko vorbereiten
die torten bilden sie nichts gebacken
die kanals ist auch schon fertig und ich
möchte jetzt an dieser stelle auch schon
mal die deko vorbereiten und zwar mache
ich ja die von dort hatte mit einem
aufleger und zwar habe ich hier mir so
ein gesicht rausgesucht so ein mini maus
kopf den habe ich jetzt ausgedruckt und
gleich auch schon ausgeschnitten und den
werde ich jetzt machen weil da eben auch
durch trocknen muss und wird die
dekoration benutze ich jetzt die zutaten
also ich habe hier etwas modelle
schokolade deko job hier etwas zucker
kleber das zeige ich mich gleich wie man
den herstellt und zwar wird er aus
zellulose pulver hergestellt zum
ausrollen brauche ich etwas becker
stärke und eventuell etwas palm ihn also
kokosfett und ich nehme immer ganz gern
deko schock an den stellen wo ich von
dort nicht nehmen möchte oder es einfach
ersetzen kann
der job ist nämlich module schokolade
schmeckt eben natürlich auch viel besser
und vielleicht habt ihr das auch schon
mal entdeckt da ist nämlich von mir hier
dieses logo mit drauf und ein qr-code
und wenn ihr das mit dem handy ab scans
da könnt ihr dann einfach mal auf das
also da kommen direkt auf ein video und
da erkläre ich euch wie man dieses
produkt eben genau benutzt also finde
ich ganz praktisch und ich benutze es
eben immer dann wenn ich von dort nicht
nehmen möchte weil von dort mir meistens
zu süß ist oder nehme ich eben gerne die
alternative und jetzt nehme ich hier
bereits die farbe schwarz also schwarz
schwarz herr modell ist gerade und da
brauche ich jetzt ein
und geht es erst mal weich also bei
modellierter gerade ist das motiviert
hat weicht durch die wärme und später
wird sie natürlich auch wieder hart wenn
sie wieder kalt wird
[Musik]
aber weil ich jetzt möchte das jetzt
schneller durch trocknet nehme ich auch
hier etwas zellulose pulver dieses cmc
dadurch wird es nämlich fester also das
nimmt man auch ganz gerne bei von dort
wenn man einfach etwas modellieren
möchte was eben fest werden soll
das könnte ich jetzt hier kurz ein und
jetzt nehme ich mir hier meine zwei
holzstäbchen und rollt es auf 10 mm
stärke aus mit etwas becker sterkel
und jetzt schneidet hier diesen minimal
aus kopf aus ich nehme etwas kamin und
gefettet damit jetzt die modelle
schokolade dann klebt nämlich das papier
eben besser drauf ich habe mir das jetzt
als vorlage schon ausgeschnitten und
habe hier auch die schleife
weggeschnitten also dass ich jetzt
einfach nur diese mini maus kopf habe
dann lege ich mir denn da drauf
und kann jetzt mit einem cuttermesser
aus und rumschreit
[Musik]
und die reste könnt ihr einfach in etwas
frischhaltefolie einwickeln oder in eine
kleine tüte daneben so eine box
verschließen und im kühlschrank
aufbewahren und einfach das nächste mal
wieder verwenden also die sind
eigentlich fast ähnlich hart aber jetzt
sehe ich hier das papier weg und jetzt
können damit den händen noch so ein
bisschen nach formen wenn ihr irgendwie
ungerade ecken und kanten habt oder
wegen euch was nicht gefällt also das
ist auch das tolle an der modelle
schokolade
ihr könnt sie eigentlich noch ziemlich
lange nach formen durch die hand wärme
aber mir gefällt das sind so schon ganz
gut
und weil ich das später jetzt auf die
torte draufsetzen möchte muss ich jetzt
noch 26 spieler an bringen damit ich die
eben später auch befestigen kann
und ich muss mir das jetzt erstmal ab
die sollen nämlich jetzt fast bis ganz
oben hin gehen und dann auch fast bis
100 orte und jetzt schneide ich mir hier
mal so ein stück ab das ist jetzt
ungefähr 15 cm
das mache es lieber etwas länger und
kann sie später nochmals setzen jetzt
auch ich die spitze in etwas zucker
kleber dann hat es auch schön dran
und jetzt können das hier einfach rein
stecken
[Musik]
und da müsste jetzt auch mal die
rückseite kontrollieren die muss nämlich
auch schön aussehen die sieht man zwar
nicht auf den ersten blick aber ich
finde auch eine torte muss von hinten
schön aussehen deswegen mache ich es
auch hinten immer ganz hübsch und damit
die oberfläche jetzt wieder schön glatt
weg nehme ich so ein von twitter und
streich einfach so ein bisschen drüber
denn man kommt ja immer mit den fingern
mal so ein bisschen dran und so ist
alles ist wieder schön glatt und damit
ist jetzt noch schneller durch trocknet
setze ich das hier auf so einem
schaumstoff hat und lass es ganz kurz
antrocknen und riecht schon mal die
nächsten dekorationselemente hin
als nächstes mache ich jetzt das mini
maus gesichts habe ich mir jetzt auch
schon mal ausgeschnitten und da muss ich
mir jetzt diese hautfarbe aus weiß-
rosa- und ich nehme etwas gelbe
lebensmittelfarbe
[Musik]
die hautfarbe habe ich jetzt etwas
dünner ausgerollt damit das gesicht
schön flach auflegt und bevor ich das
jetzt aber aus schneide lass ich's kurz
antrocknen dann kann ich nämlich besser
schneiden und kann ihn derzeit aber
schon mal die schleife herstellen
die schleife möchte ich jetzt relativ
dünn machen deswegen verknetet jetzt
rosa farbene modelle schokolade mit so
ein bisschen blüten passte damit es dann
einfach dünner aus roller ist und
schneller austrocknet
[Musik]
und mit weiß abbilden passte stecke ich
mir jetzt hier diese punkte aus das
mache ich jetzt mit seiner spritztour
aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch schon
ein strohhalm nehmen
und damit ausstechen
und wenn es mal nicht rauskommt einfach
mit einem schaschlikspieß ausdrücken
[Musik]
und die werden dann auch mit etwas
zucker kleber angeklebt
[Musik]
jetzt soll ich dann nochmal drüber dann
verbindet sich das weiß auch schon mit
dem rosa
[Musik]
mit schneide ich mir hier ein rechteck
zurecht und zwar hat es jetzt 8 auf etwa
4 cm
es darf jetzt auch nicht zu groß sein
meine erste schleife wollen wir auch zu
groß deswegen mache ich jetzt noch mal
kleine dann drehe ich das ganze um und
schlagt hier die seiten ein
dann wird es einmal stabiler und die
schleife wird eben auch schöner
[Musik]
jetzt hier in die mitte noch etwas
zucker thema und dann können die beiden
in unter außen eingeschlagen werden
und bevor ich das jetzt aber
zusammendrückt muss ich hier oben und
unten noch zusammendrücken
und damit die schleife nicht zu flach
gedrückt wird habe ich jetzt hier noch
diese zwei pinsel mit reingesteckt man
könnte auch schauspieler nehmen oder
einfach etwas dickeres wie zum beispiel
trinkt reichen so trinkhalme und aus dem
rest formel jetzt noch hier
dieses band in der mitte
[Musik]
und während die schleife jetzt hier noch
etwas trocknet kann ich jetzt schon mal
das gesicht ausschneiden
und dann könnt ihr das gesicht schon mal
direkt aufkleben
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich diese vorlage als
hilfe legt sie auf das gesicht drauf und
zeichne einfach mal die konturen nach
also mit diesem cuttermesser dann habt
doch später einfacher beim dekorieren
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich noch mit einem
kleinen schwarzen stück modelle
schokolade die nase
[Musik]
und warum die schleife hier jetzt etwas
an trocknet kann ich schon mal hier die
kontur machen und dafür mache ich mir
jetzt ganz feine linien aus modelle
schokolade
das mache ich jetzt in meiner fondant
modell ihr presse das habe ich jetzt
schon weiß geknetet also dieses kleine
stück mehr werde ich auch nicht brauchen
das ist wahrscheinlich auch schon zu
viel
das kann man hier vorne einfach
einstecken und dann nehme ich mir jetzt
eine scheibe mit ganz kleinen löchern
und durch drehbewegungen bekomme ich
jetzt hier diese strenge raus
[Musik]
und die kann ich jetzt auch mit hilfe
des klebers hier außen rum geben
[Musik]
die dekoration ist vorbereitet und am
zweiten tag setzt sich dann in der regel
die torte zusammen
ich habe das jetzt alles schon
vorbereitet jetzt habe ich hier die
fertigen tortenböden und habe auch hier
bereits eine platte so eine kuchen
platte der 3 mm stärke und da setzt sich
von brandorten immer gern drauf denn da
kann ich sie einfach noch ein bisschen
bewegen und damit die torte nicht
verrutscht streiche ich ein bisschen
komisch drauf dann kommt der erste boden
die kanals nehme ich jetzt auch als
füllung aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch
eine marmelade nehmen
die habe ich jetzt vorbei so ein
bisschen durchgeführt und streicht die
jetzt auch hier rein schmeckt hat
richtig schön schokoladig
[Musik]
und dann setzte ich noch den zweiten
boden drauf
und jetzt bestreite ich die torte
erstmal rundherum ganz gegen mittag aß
[Musik]
und dieser erste schicht muss jetzt noch
gar nicht so perfekt sein denn die dient
nur dazu dass die krümel gebunden werden
die torte später eben nicht krümelt
jetzt stelle ich die torte erstmal im
kühlschrank für etwa 15 bis 20 minuten
und dann kommt noch mal die zweite
schicht drauf jetzt ist die torte schön
kalt und ich kann jetzt die zweite
schicht auftragen und das wird jetzt die
glatte schicht
die tat steht jetzt im kühlschrank und
nicht bereit jetzt schon mal die
dekoration vor
ich habe jetzt hier 750 gramm von dort
seien nämlich immer ganz gerne den hier
da habe ich jetzt den fertigen rosa
angenommen von deco bak und der ist
jetzt auch schon schön weich denn die
temperaturen sind ziemlich hoch
aber dennoch muss ich ihnen natürlich
durchkneten du bekommst auch ein stück
[Musik]
und es rollt ihr am besten auf etwas
becker stärker aus
und wenn die torte jetzt zu trocken ist
können dass sie gerne mit etwas back
transfer einfetten
aber meine ist noch feucht genug und ich
kann die vorband der games direkt
darüber legen
[Musik]
die
den überschuss nämlich jetzt mit einem
messer weg
und den rest könnte einfach in eine
gefriertruhe packen dann in der stube
schüssel rhein und im kühlschrank
aufbewahren
warum jetzt nehme ich mir hier so zwei
glätte und geht er die torte schön von
allen seiten
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich hier so ein ecken
format das heißt wer ihr da oben dieser
ecke nicht so schön habt könnt ihr das
hier mitmachen und hier einfach so
drumherum fall natürlich nur wenig
gerade kanten halt das ganze gibt es
auch im rund damit kann man runde kanten
machen aber ich möchte jetzt nicht
gerade karte
[Musik]
und für den rand unten gibt's das ganze
auch noch mal
als nächstes stehe ich jetzt noch ein
paar dekoelemente her und zwar möchte
ich da vorne auf der torte so ein
kleines namensschild deswegen nehme ich
wieder mal weiße modell wie schokolade
und rollen sie aus und auch schwarze und
schlecht dann mit diesen zwar ausstechen
so kleine schilder aus
[Musik]
ich habe die torte zum gesetz und möchte
jetzt noch hier unten den abschluss
machen aber ich möchte ich an der stelle
jetzt noch zeigen wie man diesen zucker
kleber herstellt und zwar habe ich hier
dieses zellulose pulver unternehme ich
jetzt so ein viertel teelöffel davon so
einfach den rest und für mich ist mit
etwas wasser das ist jetzt so ungefähr
50 milliliter und das wasser ist frisch
abgekocht als er noch ganz heiß und es
verrührt ihr jetzt kurz miteinander aber
das gibt so einen großen klumpen hier
drin
der löst sich aber jetzt gleich wieder
auf wenn das ganze abkühlt und diesen
zucker kleber nehme ich immer ganz gerne
weil er schnell trocknet und ich so die
sachen schnell aneinander befestigen
kann
ansonsten nimmt ihr einfach wasser aber
da dauert der trocknungsprozess eben
etwas länger
und den kann man auch einfach im
kühlschrank aufbewahren wenn man da
immer mit einem frischen pinsel reingeht
geht er auch nicht kaputt und dann kann
man den mehrere monate aufheben
und genau mit diesem zucker kleber klebe
ich hier unten jetzt noch ein paar
streusel an und zwar passt es ganz gut
da gibt es nämlich auch von walt disney
von deco back dieser zucker streusel in
form von mini maus und hier nämlich
jetzt diese mini maus köpfe und habe aus
einem anderen set noch so kleine
schwarze kristalle und ein paar
pinkfarbene kristalle jetzt bestreicht
hier unten den rand ganz leicht zucker
kleber und dann haben wir auch gleich
einen schönen abschluss
[Musik]
und als letztes kommt jetzt noch der
aufleger oder der aufsteller drauf das
muss ich gucken dass ich das so ziemlich
mittig hinbekomme
[Musik]
jetzt können wir die torte anschneiden
nur so anschneiden
naja jetzt darfst du probieren
[Musik]
und hat ihnen verstecken minnie mouse
schmeckt super das freut mich
also wenn es der kleinen schmeckt
schmeckt auch allen anderen den samira
ist mein größter kritiker nachgehen
eigentlich vor morath ist amira und dann
dem rat und wenn er jetzt auch diese
torte nach machen wollt könnt ihr
einfach auf meinem blog gehen auf salehs
- blog.de da stehen noch mal genaue
mengenangaben und nochmal die genaue
zubereitung und ich danke euch fürs
einschalten
ihr könnt gerne euch auch ein motiv
torte von mir wünschen was soll ich als
nächstes nach machen und ich freue mich
schon auf euer feedback bis bald auch
tschüss
jedes schweigt und genießt
hat ja noch nicht mal wie kanal ab
[Musik]